A few months ago, somebody said something to me that I found so humiliating that I have never talked about it. Not to anybody. Not even with the people I love the most. This is way too embarrassing. It makes me wince even to think of it. But telling my loved ones and my friends, that's real life. Those are people I have to live with. You and me, here, right now, on the radio, we have a different kind of relationship, right? I can tell you.
几个月前，有人对我说了一些让我觉得极其羞辱的话，以至于我从未向任何人提起过。谁都没说过。即使是对我最亲爱的人也是如此。这实在是太尴尬了。一想到这件事，我就感到难为情。但向我所爱的人和朋友诉说，那才是真实的生活。他们是我必须共同生活的人。而你和我，此时此刻，在广播里，我们有着一种不同的关系，对吧？我可以告诉你。
So this thing happened while I was still riding around the city on this poncy little folding bike, which looks ridiculous, and there's no dignity to it, but it is handy to have a bike that folds up if you live in the city. And it was maybe 9:00 PM. And I was riding home from work, and I was wearing a suit because I'd been to work. And that morning, it had been cold, so I wore a coat, even though now, at night, it was warm enough, so the coat was unnecessary, but it was just easier to wear the coat than to be carrying it.
这事发生在我还骑着那辆看起来很滑稽的小折叠自行车在城里转悠的时候，骑那种车一点尊严都没有，但如果你住在城里，有一辆能折叠的自行车确实很方便。当时大概是晚上9点。我正骑车下班回家，因为刚上完班，所以我穿着西装。那天早上天很冷，所以我穿了件外套，尽管到了晚上已经足够暖和，外套显得多余，但穿着它总比提着它省事。
I was also wearing one of those-- you know those reflective orange and yellow vests? I was wearing it because I'd had three bike accidents, thanks to the fact that the folding bike loses its grip on the street in the rain. Extra precaution seemed worth it. I don't know. I have gray hair at that point, a neatly trimmed beard. I was wearing a helmet. All in all, I was a picture of fastidious care.
我还穿了那种——你知道那种橙色和黄色的反光背心吗？我穿它是为了防范，因为我有过三次自行车事故，多亏了那辆折叠车在雨天的路面上抓地力很差。多加点防护措施似乎是值得的。我不知道。那时我已经有了灰白的头发，留着修剪整齐的胡子。我戴着头盔。总之，我看起来是一副谨小慎微的样子。
I was going south on Avenue B. I was between 3rd and 2nd Street. A young woman was traipsing across the street, not wearing a coat, full of cheerful, loose energy, bright eyes. She sees me on the bike. I am this locked down, buttoned down, helmeted, overdressed, gray-haired man in a reflective vest. And as I rode past her, the thing she says to me is, "Do you fart out the front?" That's all she said. "Do you fart out the front?"
我正沿着B大道向南行驶，在第三街和第二街之间。一位年轻女子正慢悠悠地过马路，没穿外套，充满了一种欢快、松弛的活力，眼神明亮。她看到了骑车的我。我是一个全副武装、扣子扣得严严实实、戴着头盔、穿得太多、满头白发、还穿着反光背心的男人。当我骑车经过她身边时，她对我说了句：“你是从前面放屁吗？”她就说了这一句。“你是从前面放屁吗？”
It was really kind of stunning. [LAUGHS] As an insult, it's both incredibly efficient and deeply mysterious. I don't even get what image she's trying to convey, in a literal sense. But I do think I get the feeling she's going for, and it's not respectful, you know? It's kind of like, you fussy, foppish, overcareful old man.
这真是令人震惊。[笑声] 作为一种侮辱，它既极其高效，又深不可测。从字面上看，我甚至不明白她想表达什么形象。但我确实明白她想要的那种感觉，而且那绝不是尊重的意思，你懂吗？它就像在说，你这个挑剔、浮夸、过度谨慎的老头子。
And can I say, that thought she had, she could have kept that to herself. I think all kinds of things about people on the street all the time. I keep those thoughts to myself. I do not say those things to people, to their faces, because they are strangers. They are complete strangers. They don't need to know.
我能说的是，她当时的想法，她完全可以憋在心里。我走在街上时，也总是会对人产生各种各样的想法。但我把那些想法留给自己。我不会当面把那些话对人说出来，因为他们是陌生人。他们是彻头彻尾的陌生人。他们不需要知道。
But of course, it is so much easier to say what you really think with a complete stranger. With our friends, with our loved ones, it can be so much more difficult to be honest, sometimes. Right?
但当然，对一个彻头彻尾的陌生人说出你真实的想法要容易得多。对于我们的朋友，对于我们所爱的人，有时候想要诚实坦率确实要困难得多。对吧？
When somebody you really know and you have some tough truth that you need to talk through with them, the math of figuring out when to tell them and what to say and should you actually get into it and say anything at all, it can be so complicated. Like, sometimes you tell them, and the two of you talk it through and work it out, and it is relationship changing. It's vital. It is so important. And sometimes, annoyingly, it fucking blows up in your face.
当某个你真正了解的人有某种棘手的真相需要与你探讨时，计算什么时候告诉他们、该说什么，以及是否真的应该深入探讨并说出一切，这可能非常复杂。比如，有时候你告诉了他们，你们俩谈开了并解决了问题，那将改变你们的关系。这至关重要。这非常重要。而有时候，让人恼火的是，这可能会当场炸开。
Today, on our program, we have stories of two friendships. And in each of these friendships, one of the friends has something to say to the other, something big, and they have to decide, do I say it to their face? In each of these stories, they make a decision, and then that is actually when it gets interesting. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天，在我们的节目中，我们将讲述两段友谊的故事。在每一段友谊中，其中一个朋友都有话要对另一个说，那是件大事，他们必须决定：我是该当面告诉他吗？在每一个故事里，他们都做出了决定，而那才是事情真正变得有趣的时候。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act 1, "What Are Friends For? No, Seriously. What are They For?" So we start today with somebody who had something that he needed to talk through with his friend. And rather than have the tough conversation and get things off his chest and come to some new understanding, he did not do that. No, no, no. Instead, he stewed about it for years. And then he talked about it to everyone, everyone, but the one person that he really needed to talk to. Aviva DeKornfeld explains how that worked out for him.
第一幕，“朋友是干什么用的？不，说真的，他们到底是干什么用的？”今天我们从一个人开始，他有件事需要和他的朋友谈谈。但他没有进行那次艰难的谈话，没有把心里的话说出来并达成某种新的共识，他没有那样做。不，不，不。相反，他为此苦恼了好几年。然后他把这件事告诉了所有人，所有人，唯独没告诉他真正需要交谈的那个人。艾薇瓦·德科恩菲尔德解释了这对他产生了怎样的影响。
The thing Gabe Mollica accidentally got stuck thinking about was a friendship breakup, and he got stuck there for a long time, eight years. And then he took all those thoughts and did the thing that only a former theater kid would do-- he compiled them into a one-man show. That's how I first heard about this story. I went to see Gabe's show one night because friendship is something I'm stuck thinking about, too. I recently went through a friend breakup myself.
盖布·莫利卡不小心陷入其中无法自拔的事情是一次友谊的破裂，而且他在那里面困了很久，八年。然后他把所有这些想法变成了只有曾经的戏剧社孩子才会做的事——他把它们编成了一场独角戏。我就是那样第一次听到这个故事的。有一天晚上我去看盖布的戏，因为友谊也是我一直困惑的事情。我自己最近也经历了一次朋友破裂。
Gabe's a small-time comedian, lives in Queens. Has a day job teaching kids how to write essays. And he starts his show by saying he doesn't have any real friends. What he has is a group of bros-- his word-- from high school. And his relationship with them is very stereotypically bro-like.
盖布是个小有名气的喜剧演员，住在皇后区。有一份教孩子们写作文的日常工作。他在节目开头说他没有什么真正的朋友。他拥有的是一群高中时代的“兄弟”——这是他的原话。他与他们的关系非常典型地像兄弟。
They do lots of activities together-- watch sports, play video games-- but never get into the nitty gritty of what's going on in one another's emotional lives. Like, for example, in the show, Gabe describes spending the whole day with his closest friend of the bros, Nick, and then afterwards, going over to his parents' house in Long Island.
他们一起做很多活动——看体育比赛、玩电子游戏——但从不深入讨论彼此情感生活中的核心问题。比如，在演出中，盖布描述了自己和兄弟中最亲近的朋友尼克呆了一整天，之后，又去了他在长岛的父母家。
And I walked through the front door. And as soon as I do, my mom spots me and she goes, oh, my God, Gabe. You were just with Nick. I just saw on Facebook that Nick's sister just had a baby. How does Nick feel about being an uncle? And I was like, what? How does Nick feel about being-- I was like, I've known Nick my entire life, but I don't know how Nick feels about anything.
然后我走进前门。我刚一进去，我妈就发现了我，她说，天哪，盖布。你刚才和尼克在一起。我刚在Facebook上看到尼克的妹妹刚生了个孩子。尼克对当舅舅有什么感觉？我说，什么？尼克对当……我说，我认识尼克一辈子了，但我不知道尼克对任何事有什么感觉。
But I've seen the way my mother and my sister hang out with their friends. In the afternoon, they get a cup of coffee. At night, they have a glass of wine. This is key-- they look at each other. For them, the activity is each other. And for us, the activity is literally anything else. And for a long time, truly, hand to God, this did not bother me at all.
但我见过我母亲和我妹妹与她们的朋友相处的方式。下午，她们会喝杯咖啡。晚上，她们会喝杯酒。这是关键——她们会注视着对方。对她们来说，活动就是彼此。而对我们来说，活动实际上是任何其他事情。很长一段时间里，真的，向上帝发誓，这完全没有困扰过我。
But then something hard happened. And for the first time in his adult life, Gabe needed more from his friends than just a good hang. What happened is, his mom got sick. She checked into the hospital, and for weeks, doctors can't figure out what's wrong with her. One afternoon, Gabe leaves the hospital to go walk the family dog, and it's his first real moment of quiet since everything happened. He talks about this on his show, and I asked him about it. He said he texted Nick to update him on his mom's status.
但后来发生了一件棘手的事。在他成年后的生活中，第一次，盖布需要从朋友那里得到不仅仅是一起玩乐的东西。事情是这样的，他母亲病了。她住进了医院，几周以来，医生都查不出她得了什么病。一天下午，盖布离开医院去遛家里的狗，这是自从一切发生以来他第一次真正安静的时刻。他在他的节目中谈到了这一点，我问了他。他说他给尼克发了短信，告知了他母亲的近况。
And he responds by telling me she might be eligible for workers' comp. You might be able to get some money for this. And I'm reading that text and realizing that that is not what I'm interested in hearing about. I wasn't asking for legal advice. I was asking-- I was, in my own way, trying to get somebody to be like, hey, man, that's scary. Are you all right?
他回复说，她可能符合工伤赔偿条件。你或许能从中得到一些钱。我读着那条短信，意识到那根本不是我想听的内容。我不是在寻求法律建议。我是在……我是在用我自己的方式，试图让某个人能说：嘿，伙计，那太可怕了。你还好吗？
Like, I'm here for you.
比如，我在这里支持你。
Yeah. Yeah, I'm here for you. How are you feeling?
是的。是的，我支持你。你感觉怎么样？
Not, "you may be entitled to compensation."
而不是，“你可能有权获得赔偿。”
Yeah. Yeah, it was very Cellino & Barnes. And I think I was upset that he was just kind of missing the mark on what I needed. And so when he sent me that, it really made me feel alone. It made me feel like, what if I don't have anybody to be that in my life? Somebody who just gets it without having to be explained.
是的。是的，这简直太像那种广告了。我想我很难过，因为他完全没能理解我真正需要的是什么。所以当他发给我那个时，这真的让我感到孤独。这让我觉得，如果我生活中没有这样的人怎么办？那种不需要解释就能明白的人。
Have you ever had that?
你有过那种经历吗？
I had a best friend named Tim. And we were very, very close. And he was kind of like my guy for a couple of years. And it was really special.
我曾有一个最好的朋友叫蒂姆。我们非常非常亲密。有几年他就像我的心腹。那真的很特别。
When Gabe talks about this in his show, this is where he pivots. From here, it turns into this long ode to the only friend Gabe had ever had who would have known what to say when his mom got sick, this guy named Tim, who he'd broken up with years ago, but still hasn't gotten over because of the abrupt way it ended. It's haunted him for years. This is the thing I'm going to tell you about-- Gabe's one emotionally intimate friendship with another guy and the conversation they should have had that could have changed everything.
当盖布在节目中谈到这一点时，这是他转变的地方。从这里开始，这变成了一首长长的颂歌，献给他唯一一个在母亲生病时知道该说什么的朋友，这个叫蒂姆的人，他多年前与他绝交了，但因为那种突然的结束方式，他一直没有走出来。这件事困扰了他多年。这就是我要告诉你的事情——盖布与另一个男人之间唯一一段情感亲密的友谊，以及他们本该有的一次对话，那本可以改变一切。
Gabe met Tim his sophomore year of college at Hamilton in poetry class. Gabe noticed him right away, because he managed to analyze poetry in a way that somehow didn't feel pretentious. He seemed sort of casually brilliant. So one day after class, Gabe strikes up a conversation with Tim. They walk across campus, talking.
盖布是在大学二年级汉密尔顿学院的诗歌课上遇到蒂姆的。盖布立刻注意到了他，因为他分析诗歌的方式不知为何让人觉得并不做作。他似乎有一种随意的才华。所以课后有一天，盖布主动与蒂姆交谈。他们穿过校园，聊着天。
Tim tells him that he played varsity baseball in high school, which is very impressive to Gabe, because while he'd happily accepted his fate as a musical theater nerd, he still hadn't quite kicked that straight guy urge to be good at sports. Tim, then, asks Gabe what he did in high school.
蒂姆告诉他，他高中时是校棒球队的，这让盖布印象深刻，因为虽然他很乐意接受自己作为音乐剧极客的命运，但他依然还没完全改掉那种直男想在运动上出色的冲动。于是，蒂姆问盖布高中时做了什么。
And I'm like, yeah, man, I was in musicals. I was a little sheepish telling him, I remember. And he kind of lights up when he hears musicals. And he's like, dude, I love musicals. He's like, what have you been in? And I start telling him, Little Shop of Horrors, and Oklahoma, and all this stuff. And I'm like, have you ever been in a musical? Like, you do all this stuff.
我说，是啊，伙计，我演音乐剧。我记得我告诉他时还有点害羞。当他听到音乐剧时，他眼睛亮了。他说，哥们，我超爱音乐剧。他说，你演过什么？我开始告诉他，《恐怖小店》，《俄克拉荷马》，还有所有这些东西。我说，你演过音乐剧吗？因为你做过所有这些事。
And he's like, well, I was in one show junior year of high school. I was in Guys and Dolls. And I'm like, oh, that's crazy. I was in Guys and Dolls. Who did you play? And he says, I played Sky Masterson. And I'm like, oh, I also played Sky Masterson. And so we have this moment where we're kind of just like looking at each other like, oh, that's weird. Like junior year of high school, we played the same character.
他说，嗯，我高中三年级演过一部剧。我演了《红男绿女》。我说，哦，那太疯狂了。我也演过《红男绿女》。你演谁？他说，我演了斯凯·马斯特森。我说，哦，我也演了斯凯·马斯特森。于是我们有那么一刻，就只是看着对方，心想，哦，这太奇怪了。高中三年级，我们演了同一个角色。
From there, Gabe and Tim fell into that kind of all-consuming friendship you fall into when you're young, when you have time for that kind of thing. This newfound relationship felt different from Gabe's high school friendships. He and Tim could talk about real stuff.
从那时起，盖布和蒂姆陷入了那种年轻时会陷入的全身心投入的友谊，那是你有时间做那种事的时候。这种新建立的关系与盖布高中时的友谊感觉不同。他和蒂姆可以谈论真正的事情。
We would talk about family stuff. We'd talk about money stuff. We'd talk about the sacrifices our parents were making.
我们会谈论家里的事。我们会谈论钱的问题。我们会谈论父母作出的牺牲。
For you guys to go to college?
为了你们去上大学？
Yeah. Both of us were on financial aid. Both of us kind of had this chip on our shoulder, like we didn't necessarily belong there. And so we kind of had this understanding. We just got each other.
是的。我们俩都有助学金。我们俩都有种怀才不遇的感觉，好像我们并不一定属于那里。所以我们有了这种默契。我们就是彼此理解。
Tim and Gabe would regularly stay up till 4:00 AM, smoking clove cigarettes and debating the kind of stuff you debate about in college. A year passed like this. Then Tim invited Gabe to come work with him at the summer camp for kids with chronic illnesses.
蒂姆和盖布经常熬夜到凌晨4点，抽着丁香烟，争论你在大学里会争论的那种事情。一年就是这样过去的。然后蒂姆邀请盖布和他一起去给患有慢性病的儿童举办的夏令营工作。
Gabe joined him and found he loved it, in part because one night at camp, Tim introduced Gabe to another counselor, Kate. Gabe remembers Tim telling him, you're going to love Kate. She's our kind of person. Tim was right. Gabe and Kate talked for hours. And at the end of the night, they walked back to their bunks together.
盖布加入了，他发现自己很喜欢这个夏令营，部分原因是夏令营的一个晚上，蒂姆把盖布介绍给了另一位辅导员凯特。盖布记得蒂姆对他说的，你会喜欢凯特的。她是咱们同类的人。蒂姆说对了。盖布和凯特聊了几个小时。那天晚上结束时，他们一起走回营房。
And so we're doing this walk, and it's very romantic. And she kind of just like leans in, and we kiss. And something kind of goes off, at least in my brain, where I was like, whatever I need to do to hold on to this. This is like a real one.
于是我们正走着，那真的很浪漫。她凑过来，我们接吻了。某种东西在我脑海中被触发了，当时我想的是，无论我需要做什么来留住这个。这是一段真正的缘分。
The rest of the summer is dreamy. But Gabe has to leave camp a couple weeks early to start a teaching job in Scotland. He and Kate stay in touch. They're actually in contact all the time, texting, emailing, sending poems back and forth. But the more time passes, the less into it Kate seems to be. Eventually, she calls Gabe and breaks things off.
那个夏天的余下时间就像梦一样。但盖布必须提前几周离开夏令营去苏格兰开始一份教职工作。他和凯特保持着联系。他们实际上一直都在联系，发短信、发邮件、互相寄诗。但随着时间的推移，凯特看起来似乎不那么投入了。最终，她打电话给盖布并提出了分手。
Gabe was upset and wrote to Tim to tell him the news. Tim responded, saying he was sorry to hear about Kate and that he loved him. Tim and Gabe and some of their camp friends had planned a New Year's trip to reunite in Edinburgh, but when they arrive, it's not fun at all, at least not for Gabe. All he wants to do is hang out with Tim one-on-one and talk about Kate, but--
盖布很难过，写信告诉蒂姆这个消息。蒂姆回复说，他很遗憾听到关于凯特的事，并且他爱他。蒂姆、盖布和他们的一些夏令营朋友计划了一次新年旅行在爱丁堡重聚，但当他们到达时，一点也不开心，至少对盖布来说是这样。他只想和蒂姆单独相处，聊聊凯特，但是——
Tim and I are not really talking that much.
我和蒂姆其实并没有怎么说话。
Why not?
为什么不呢？
I don't know. Yeah, it felt like he wasn't really interested in spending alone time with me.
我不知道。是的，感觉他并不真的想和我单独相处。
Finally, days into the trip, Tim asked Gabe to hang out, just them. Gabe is thrilled. It feels like the trip he actually wanted to have is finally starting. They go to a casino, then walk back to Gabe's apartment, where Gabe starts making them a late night snack.
最终，旅行几天后，蒂姆邀请盖布出来聚聚，就他们俩。盖布很兴奋。感觉他真正想要的旅行终于开始了。他们去了赌场，然后走回盖布的公寓，盖布开始给他们做深夜点心。
I think I had frozen pizza bagels or something, and I preheated the oven. And Tim is sitting on my kitchen counter. And he says, Gabe, life sucks and then you die.
我想我当时有冷冻披萨百吉饼之类的东西，我预热了烤箱。蒂姆坐在我的厨房台面上。他说，盖布，生活糟透了，然后你就死了。
Just out of the blue?
突如其来的？
Just out of the blue. He's wearing a hat, and he's sitting on my counter. He's kind of just staring off. He's like, life sucks and then you die. And I'm like, what's up?
突如其来的。他戴着帽子，坐在我的台面上。他有点出神。他说，生活糟透了，然后你就死了。我说，怎么了？
What do you think is going on?
你觉得发生了什么？
I think at a certain point, there's a part of you that kind of knows things that are going to happen before they happen. And you're like, please, anything else. You know?
我觉得在某个时刻，你内心深处会预感到将要发生的事情。你会想，求你了，任何别的事情都行。你知道吗？
You're like, no, no, no, no, no, preparing for impact?
你是想说，不，不，不，不，不，正在准备迎接冲击？
Yeah. He's basically like, Kate and I got together, and we're not sorry. We're not going to apologize for it. This is kind of like what happened. We're together. And you're going to have to deal with that. That's what's going on.
是的。他基本上说的是，我和凯特在一起了，我们并不感到抱歉。我们不会为此道歉。事情就是这样发生的。我们在一起了。而你必须接受这个事实。这就是发生了什么。
What do you say?
你怎么说？
I was mad. I think I yelled. I was like, what do you mean? I want an explanation. You're not thinking about how you're coming across. You're just like, what are you talking about?
我很生气。我想我大喊大叫了。我说，你什么意思？我要一个解释。你根本没想过你的做法会让人怎么想。你只是……你在说什么？
Are there specific moments that you look back at differently after Tim revealed to you the truth?
在蒂姆向你揭露真相后，是否有特定的时刻让你有了不同的回顾？
Yeah, it makes you revisit. It makes you revisit the summer. There's staff party pictures of them hanging out. And the night of the staff party, I was in Edinburgh, and I couldn't sleep. And there was pictures of them together. And I remember kind of zooming in, like, where are their hands? Is this intimate? Am I--
是的，这让你重新审视。这让你重新审视那个夏天。有他们在一起玩的员工聚会照片。员工聚会那天晚上，我在爱丁堡，我睡不着。照片里他们在一起。我记得我放大了看，心想，他们的手在哪？这是亲密的吗？我是不是——
Where were their hands?
他们的手在哪？
Her hand was kind of like by his waist. And I was like--
她的手大约是在他的腰部附近。我当时想——
Too low.
太低了。
Too low! Too low.
太低了！太低了。
I did talk to Kate about all this. She said she had liked Gabe. But when she fell for Tim, it felt like they were beginning the big relationship of their lives. And that's what Tim tried to emphasize to Gabe. But even with that being the case, it's pretty intense to say, I'm not sorry.
我就这一切与凯特谈过。她说她确实喜欢过盖布。但当她爱上蒂姆时，感觉他们开始了他们一生中最重大的关系。而这正是蒂姆试图向盖布强调的。但即使如此，说“我不抱歉”还是相当强烈的。
Yeah.
是的。
He really said that?
他真的那么说了？
In my recollection, yeah. He was just like-- or he was like, I'm not going to apologize. I'm not going to--
在我的记忆中，是的。他只是说——或者他说，我不会道歉。我不会——
Right. Like admit guilt.
对。就像承认有罪一样。
Yeah. Yeah, it was like dealing with a corporation. Like, here's your settlement, but we're not going to admit any guilt. And I kind of kept waiting for him to be like, dude, I feel awful.
是的。是的，这就像和一家大公司打交道。比如，这是你的和解协议，但我们不会承认任何罪过。我一直在等他说，哥们，我感觉糟透了。
Would that have helped?
那会有所帮助吗？
I think so, yeah. I like to think there's a way he could have done that that didn't end the friendship.
我想会的，是的。我愿意相信有一种方式他可以做到而不结束这段友谊。
This is what Gabe can't wrap his head around-- why Tim did it in this way. He could deal with the breakup with Kate. There's a script for that kind of heartache. It was Gabe's breakup with Tim that really hurt because it wasn't supposed to happen. It's not part of the friendship contract. It felt impossible to square the coldness of what Tim had done with the guy Gabe believed his friend to be.
这就是盖布无法理解的地方——为什么蒂姆要以这种方式做。他能应对与凯特的分手。那种心碎有固定的剧本。真正伤人的是盖布与蒂姆的分手，因为那本不该发生。这不在友谊契约里。盖布认为蒂姆是一个那样的人，这种冷漠与他心目中的朋友形象无法调和。
Eight years have passed since then. Gabe keeps expecting him to reach out because in Gabe's mind, Tim's the one who broke the relationship. So it was on him to fix it. But they still haven't talked about what happened. Even though Tim and Kate broke up years ago, they'd been engaged before that. In Gabe's show, he tells the whole story, how he and Tim met, camp, Scotland, why they stopped talking, and what he wishes he could say to Tim now.
从那以后八年过去了。盖布一直在等他主动联系，因为在盖布看来，是蒂姆打破了这段关系。所以修复它是他的责任。但他们仍然没有谈过发生了什么。尽管蒂姆和凯特多年前就分手了，但他们在那之前曾订过婚。在盖布的演出中，他讲述了整个故事，他和蒂姆是如何相遇的、夏令营、苏格兰、他们为什么不再说话，以及他现在希望对蒂姆说些什么。
Watching Gabe on stage, I was struck, but not surprised, by how much brain space this all still takes up for him. I know from my experience, when an important relationship implodes, detonated by one spectacularly out-of-character decision, of course, you try to make it make sense. But it's exhausting to try and put a puzzle together when you only have half the pieces. So eventually, you have to stop looking for those other pieces and make a new picture with the ones you do have.
看着台上的盖布，我深受触动，但并不惊讶这一切依然占据了他多少脑力空间。根据我的经验，当一段重要的关系轰然坍塌，被一个极其反常的决定引爆时，你当然会试图去理清它。但当你只拥有拼图的一半时，试图去拼凑它们是令人疲惫的。所以最终，你必须停止寻找那些碎片，用你现有的拼出一幅新的图画。
That's what Gabe's doing with his show. And he's hoping for something more. He wants Tim to see the show so Tim can understand what all this was like for Gabe and apologize for the way he handled Gabe's feelings. And then, maybe, he could imagine having him back as a friend. The only problem with Gabe's plan, he'd never actually invited Tim to the show.
这正是盖布在做的事。他期待着更多。他希望蒂姆能看这场戏，这样蒂姆就能理解这一切对盖布来说意味着什么，并为他处理盖布感受的方式道歉。然后，也许，他可以想象重新和他做朋友。盖布计划的唯一问题是，他从未真正邀请过蒂姆来看戏。
How long have you been doing the show?
你做这场戏多久了？
The first time I did this show was in the spring of 2019.
我第一次做这个节目是在2019年春天。
So you've been doing this show for four years?
所以你已经做这个节目四年了？
Yeah.
是的。
And you've never invited him through that whole time?
在这期间你从来没邀请过他？
No.
没有。
Even though you made the show for him.
即使你是为他做的这场戏。
Yeah. I know that sounds--
是的。我知道这听起来——
Did you think that he knew about the show?
你觉得他知道这场戏吗？
Yeah. I was pretty sure that he knows about it.
是的。我很确定他知道。
Why?
为什么？
His mom's on Facebook.
他妈在用Facebook。
Gabe's friends with Tim's mom on Facebook. So Tim must know about the show because you know, moms. Gabe assumed Tim would show up at some point. And a handful of times, he actually thought he heard Tim's laugh in the audience. It seemed crazy to me to put so much time and energy and money he didn't have into making something for essentially one person, and then stopping short of actually inviting that person to see it.
盖布在Facebook上和蒂姆的妈妈是好友。所以蒂姆一定知道这场戏，因为你知道，妈妈们。盖布以为蒂姆会在某个时候出现。有几次，他甚至以为自己在观众席里听到了蒂姆的笑声。在我看来，花这么多时间和精力，还有他不宽裕的钱，去为一个人做一些东西，却在邀请那个人来看的最后一步止步不前，这简直太疯狂了。
I'll be honest, if the thing Gabe complains about most is how men don't talk to each other about their feelings, I just want to say, dude, look in the mirror. Since he was never going to take the final step, just invite Tim himself, I asked if I could do it for him. After briefly panicking, he told me to make the call. To my surprise and Gabe's anxious delight, Tim agreed to come.
说实话，如果盖布抱怨最多的是男人之间如何不谈论感受，我只想说，哥们，照照镜子吧。既然他永远不会采取最后一步，亲自邀请蒂姆，我问他我能不能替他做。在短暂的恐慌后，他让我打了那个电话。让我和盖布焦虑的喜悦所惊讶的是，蒂姆同意来了。
We were all set. Tim had his plane ticket to New York. Gabe had grabbed a slot at a local theater and started selling tickets for the show. And then, four days before the performance, Tim emails me at midnight and says he's changed his mind. He's not going to come. He'd realized what he signed up for, flying halfway across the country to watch himself portrayed as a villain in front of a live audience, and thought, why subject myself to that?
一切都准备好了。蒂姆拿到了去纽约的机票。盖布在当地一家剧院抢到了一个档期并开始售票。然后，在演出前四天，蒂姆在午夜发邮件给我说他改变主意了。他不来了。他意识到自己签下了什么——飞越半个国家，看着自己在现场观众面前被描绘成一个反派，他心想，为什么要让自己受那种罪？
I call and text Tim, but get no response. And then, Tim finally calls me back the night before he's supposed to get on the plane to tell me his mind was made up. As it happens, Tim calls me as I'm on my way out. I'm going to a birthday dinner, where I'll see my ex-friend for the first time since she friend dumped me via text a year ago and then refused to discuss what happened.
我打电话给蒂姆并发短信，但他没有回复。然后，在蒂姆本该上飞机的前一天晚上，他终于回电话给我，说他心意已决。巧合的是，蒂姆在我准备出门时打来了电话。我要去参加一个生日晚宴，我将在那儿见到我的前朋友，那是我自一年前她通过短信解雇我，然后拒绝讨论发生了什么以来的第一次见面。
I was nauseated at the thought of seeing her, and yet, I spent the better part of an hour pacing outside the restaurant, trying to convince Tim to see his ex-friend, knowing mine was just on the other side of the restaurant door.
一想到要见到她我就感到恶心，然而，我花了近一个小时在餐馆外踱步，试图说服蒂姆去见他的前朋友，明知道我的前朋友就在餐馆门的那边。
Like, I get why he's saying no, but I tell him, most of us in this situation, we just try to avoid our ex-friend the best we can and occasionally suffer through awkward run-ins until one of us moves away or dies. But he and Gabe have this rare and kind of special chance to actually get some understanding. And I tell Tim, I hope he takes the opportunity. Tim's skeptical, but the next day, he texts me a picture from the plane.
比如，我明白他为什么拒绝，但我告诉他，我们大多数人在这种情况下，通常只是尽我们所能去躲避前朋友，偶尔忍受尴尬的相遇，直到我们中的一方搬走或去世。但他和盖布有这种罕见的、特别的机会真正达成某种理解。我告诉蒂姆，我希望他抓住这个机会。蒂姆持怀疑态度，但第二天，他给我发了一张在飞机上的照片。
Gabe heads to the theater early to get ready while I go collect Tim. Immediately, I see why Gabe liked him so much. He's warm and chatty, despite being visibly on edge. Tim and I walked to the show, talking about nothing, trying to pretend we're not strolling into a very strange situation. When we find our seats, I try to talk to Tim about how he's feeling, but he's distracted, looking around, trying to see if he recognizes anyone.
盖布提前去剧院准备，我去接蒂姆。我立刻明白了盖布为什么那么喜欢他。他很热情健谈，尽管明显很紧张。我和蒂姆步行去演出场地，聊着些无关紧要的事，试图假装我们不是正在走向一个非常奇怪的局面。当我们找到座位时，我试图和蒂姆谈谈他的感受，但他心不在焉，环顾四周，试图看看能否认出什么人。
Are you feeling happy to be here at all or no?
你在这里感觉有一点点开心吗？
I-- happy is not-- I wouldn't use the word "happy." I would say it's weird to be here, for sure, you know?
我——开心不是——我不会用“开心”这个词。我会说来到这里确实很奇怪，你知道吗？
Tim spots Gabe's mom, and then the show starts.
蒂姆发现了盖布的妈妈，然后演出了。
Gabe Mollica!
盖布·莫利卡！
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Gabe begins the show breezily, and right away, there are some jokes that really hit for Tim.
盖布开场时显得很轻松，立刻就有一些笑话深深触动了蒂姆。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
I wonder if Gabe can hear Tim's laugh from the stage. Gabe tells lots of stories from their friendship, painting them as this kind of buddy comedy duo, if Dead Poets Society were a buddy comedy.
我想知道盖布在台上能不能听到蒂姆的笑声。盖布讲述了很多他们友谊的故事，把他们描绘成一种好友喜剧搭档，如果《死亡诗社》是一部好友喜剧的话。
The way I would take an English class, so I would just always praise whatever we were reading, put me in the very unfortunate position of going to class and being like, oh, professor, another banger from Milton, you know? But Tim would walk into poetry class with like opinions and shit. You know what I mean? He'd be like, this poem's good. This one's bad. This is the best thing I've ever read.
我看英语课的方式，我总是会称赞我们读的任何东西，这让我处于一个非常不幸的境地，去上课然后说，哦，教授，弥尔顿的又一杰作，你懂的？但蒂姆会带着观点和见解走进诗歌课。你明白我的意思吗？他会说，这首诗好。那首不好。这是我读过的最棒的东西。
The show is not an 80-minute takedown. It's mostly about how much Gabe admires Tim. And yet, there are moments that are hard to watch while sitting next to Tim, like when Gabe recounts the night in Edinburgh when Tim came clean.
这场演出不是80分钟的抨击。它大部分是关于盖布有多么钦佩蒂姆。然而，有些时刻在蒂姆身边看时是很难受的，比如当盖布讲述蒂姆坦白的那晚爱丁堡的事时。
And he says, well, Kate and I are together, and we're not sorry.
他说，嗯，我和凯特在一起了，我们并不感到抱歉。
I'd pinned a mic on Tim, and the absence of sound coming from him during this part of the show was conspicuous. I'd spent hours talking to Gabe for this story, but sitting there, in the dark of the theater with Tim, no matter what had happened in the past, it seemed genuinely hard to be him in this moment. I don't think I'd appreciated the bravery all this required on Tim's part. Gabe finishes the show, triumphant. He later told me it was the best he'd ever performed.
我给蒂姆别了一个麦克，演出这段时，他那边没有声音显得格外出众。为了这个故事，我和盖布谈了几个小时，但坐在那里，和蒂姆在剧院的黑暗中，无论过去发生了什么，这一刻要当他确实显得很难。我不认为我意识到这一切需要蒂姆有多大的勇气。盖布完成了表演，大获全胜。他后来告诉我这是他表演得最好的一次。
Afterwards, Tim needs a minute to clear his head. He slips out for a walk while I stand with Gabe in front of the theater. Gabe is in the middle of showing me the clove cigarettes he doesn't smoke anymore, but bought for nostalgia's sake to smoke with Tim, when Tim appears, arms open, and pulls Gabe into a hug.
演出后，蒂姆需要一点时间清醒一下头脑。他溜出去散步，而我站在剧院门前陪着盖布。盖布正忙着向我展示他不再抽的丁香烟，那些是为了怀旧买来想和蒂姆一起抽的，这时蒂姆出现了，张开双臂，把盖布拉进了一个拥抱中。
Hey, Timmy. Thanks for coming, man.
嘿，蒂米。谢谢你来，哥们。
We drive to the studio and get right into it. Tim said it was strange to sit in the audience, hearing someone talk about him, knowing he couldn't respond. Of course, that didn't stop him from wanting to respond, like in the moment when it's revealed that he and Kate got together.
我们驱车前往录音室，直接进入了主题。蒂姆说坐在观众席里，听着别人谈论自己，知道自己无法回应，这感觉很奇怪。当然，这并没有阻止他想要回应的冲动，比如在他和凯特在一起的事情被揭露的那一刻。
The crowd goes, boo. I was like, fuck you, guys!
人群发出嘘声。我当时想，去你们的，家伙们！
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
That's my life you're booing, you know?
你们嘘的是我的生活，你知道吗？
No one booed tonight. Say ooh'd.
今晚没人嘘。是惊呼。
OK, OK.
好的，好的。
No, no, but boo is different than ooh.
不，不，但嘘和惊呼是不同的。
This is-- I agree. There's a difference.
这——我同意。是有区别。
The two reminisce for a bit, and pretty quickly, it's apparent that Tim does not remember the rise or fall of their friendship in nearly as much detail as Gabe does. There was one part, though, that Tim remembered clearly. Tim had tried at one point, in his own way, to make amends.
两人叙了一会儿旧，很快就很明显，蒂姆对他们友谊兴衰的记忆细节远没有盖布那么多。不过有一部分，蒂姆记得很清楚。蒂姆曾有一次，以他自己的方式，试图做出弥补。
A year after their breakup, he'd invited Gabe to a concert with music by the composer Edvard Grieg, which he chose specifically because there's this one song in that concert that meant a lot to both of them when they were friends. It's called "The Last Spring." Gabe first introduced the song to him in college, when he took Tim to a Grieg concert. And then a few weeks later--
在他们分手一年后，他邀请盖布去听一场音乐会，演奏的是作曲家爱德华·格里格的音乐，他选择这场音乐会是因为里面有一首曲子在他们做朋友时对他们俩意义重大。那首曲子叫《最后的春天》。盖布第一次把这首歌介绍给他是在大学时，那时他带蒂姆去听了一场格里格的音乐会。几周后——
We're like up at 3:00 AM, playing video games listening to classical music on the radio. And the song "The Last Spring" came on on the radio. And I think we just kind of like stopped talking and turned up the music and sat there and listened to it. But it was just a very special moment, as I remember it.
我们大约在凌晨3点，一边玩视频游戏，一边听广播里的古典音乐。收音机里放起了《最后的春天》。我想我们只是停止了交谈，调大了音乐，坐在那里听着。在我记忆中，那是一个非常特别的时刻。
This was the context Tim had in his head when he reached out to Gabe, thinking that maybe they could be friends again.
这就是蒂姆在试图联系盖布时的心理背景，以为他们或许能再次成为朋友。
I was like, let's go to this concert together. It's this piece of music that has this deep resonance for both of us. And my feeling was, this is a gesture of good will, of extending an olive branch. And then Gabe said no. And so, at that point, I was like, OK. Ball's in his court.
我想的是，让我们一起去听这场音乐会。这是对我们俩都有深刻共鸣的一首曲子。我的感觉是，这是一种善意的姿态，是在伸出橄榄枝。但盖布拒绝了。所以那一刻我想，好吧。球在他那边了。
Gabe, when you got that message from Tim, did you see it as the olive branch that Tim meant it to be?
盖布，当你收到蒂姆那个信息时，你把它看作蒂姆想表达的橄榄枝了吗？
I don't think I saw it as like, this is Tim putting everything on the table. My perspective was like, oh, Tim doesn't want to acknowledge the hurt he's caused. He just wants to be friends again without having to do anything, is how I felt.
我不认为我把它看作是，这是蒂姆在摊牌一切。我的看法是，哦，蒂姆不想承认他造成的伤害。他只是想重新成为朋友，而不必做任何事，我是这种感觉。
I think that perhaps my invitation to you to go to that concert, I think I was maybe overly relying on, you should feel as sentimental about this piece of music as I do and connect it to our friendship as much as I do. And so, without me explaining it, I remember feeling like the meaning behind this should be self-evident.
我想或许我对你去那场音乐会的邀请，我可能过于依赖于，你应该对这首曲子像我一样有感触，并像我一样把它与我们的友谊联系起来。所以，没有我解释它，我记得我觉得背后的意义应该是显而易见的。
Something Tim and Gabe seemed to have in common is a kind of magical thinking. Tim had hoped that Gabe would understand everything he was trying to express-- complicated feelings, like love and remorse and nostalgia-- with what was essentially a link to Ticketmaster. Gabe had expected Tim to, romcom-style, appear unannounced one night at his performance without ever actually inviting him to a show or even telling him it existed. It's like each one had all the benefit of being heard without the burden of having to say anything at all.
蒂姆和盖布似乎有一个共同点，就是一种神奇的思考。蒂姆曾希望盖布能理解他试图表达的一切——复杂的感受，比如爱、悔恨和怀旧——仅凭一个本质上是Ticketmaster的链接。盖布曾期待蒂姆以浪漫喜剧的方式，在某晚不请自来地出现在他的演出中，而从未真正邀请他看演出或告诉他其存在。就像每个人都享受了被倾听的好处，却没有任何说出哪怕一句话的负担。
The main thing Gabe wanted out of all of this was an apology for how Tim broke the news to him about Kate all those years ago. He thinks if Tim had handled it differently, they could have stayed friends. I know this is what he's waiting for. He's told me that. But an hour of circling around the topic goes by before, finally, Gabe brings it up, in a sideways sort of way.
盖布从这一切中想要的主要东西是对蒂姆多年前告诉他关于凯特的消息的方式道歉。他觉得如果蒂姆处理得不同，他们本可以维持友谊。我知道这是他在等待的。他告诉过我。但围绕这个话题盘旋了一个小时之后，终于，盖布以一种迂回的方式提了出来。
I guess a question for you is like, do you wish that it had happened differently?
我想问你一个问题，你希望当初事情以不同的方式发生吗？
Of course. Of course, I wish it had happened differently. I would tell you 1,000% I felt bad about it. I totally felt bad about it. But if I'm being totally honest, I remember that conversation differently. What I remember saying is less like, I'm not sorry, and more, I'm not asking your permission. But what I didn't want was for you to be like, yeah, Timmy, please don't do this.
当然。当然，我希望它以不同的方式发生。我会一万个百分点地告诉你我对此感到抱歉。我确实感到抱歉。但如果我完全诚实的话，我记得那次对话的内容不一样。我记得我说的是，与其说“我不抱歉”，不如说“我不需要你的许可”。但我不想你像那样说，是的，蒂米，求你别这么做。
Yeah, I mean, that's-- it's illuminating. There was always a part of me that wanted you to tell me like, I think I'm in love with her. I don't know what to do. And at least, it maybe would have given me the opportunity to be like, Timmy, I don't want to lose you as a friend. You're coming to me, and I want you to be happy. And what always was frustrating was like, it never felt like I had the chance to be the bigger man.
是的，我是说——那很有启发性。我内心一直有一部分想要你告诉我，比如，我想我爱上她了。我不知道该怎么办。至少，那可能会给我机会说，蒂米，我不想失去你这个朋友。你来找我，我希望你幸福。而一直让我沮丧的是，感觉我从来没机会表现得更大度。
That's fair, man. That's fair.
这很公平，哥们。这很公平。
Wow.
哇。
That's fair.
这很公平。
Oh, man.
哦，天哪。
No, no, that's fair because you're right. Because what I said and even what I remember saying-- you're right-- is like, I was like, I am not going to give you the chance to tell me no, or to tell me, you really don't want me to do this.
不，不，这很公平，因为你是对的。因为我说过的话，甚至我记得我说过的话——你是对的——是说，我说，我不会给你机会告诉我“不”，或者告诉我，你真的不希望我这么做。
Do you feel sorry about that, Tim?
蒂姆，你对此感到抱歉吗？
Yeah, so what I don't feel sorry for is the facts, right? The underlying-- and but what I am learning, for the first time today is that it wasn't the facts.
是的，我不抱歉的是事实，对吧？根本的——但我正在学习的是，今天第一次知道，问题并不在于事实。
No, of course not.
不，当然不是。
It's that it wasn't the fact, and well, and that's the-- you know.
问题不在于事实，嗯，那就是——你知道的。
Wait, so do you feel sorry about the way the facts came out?
等等，那你对于事实透露出来的方式感到抱歉吗？
Well, yeah, now knowing that that's the problem, yeah.
嗯，是的，现在知道那是问题所在了，是的。
Wait, you should tell Gabe that.
等等，你应该告诉盖布。
I did, I think. Didn't we?
我想我已经说了。我们不是说了吗？
Well, you didn't say the words, "I'm sorry."
嗯，你没有说“对不起”这几个字。
No, I think-- well, I thought I said that earlier in the conversation, but I am sorry for the way that I broke that news to you.
不，我想——好吧，我以为我在对话早些时候说了，但我确实为我告诉你那个消息的方式感到抱歉。
I really appreciate you saying that. Yeah, Tim, so I've been waiting a long time to hear that.
我真的很感激你说这些。是的，蒂姆，我等这一刻等了很久了。
I was surprised by how unemotional and anti-climactic the apology felt. Here Tim was, saying all the words that Gabe had wanted so badly to hear, and yet, somehow, it didn't feel like all that much. And I think that's because of this other thing that kept surfacing throughout their conversation. It's one of those awkward things that seems borderline cruel to bring attention to, but I'd be remiss not to ask. So, nervously, I do.
我惊讶于这个道歉显得多么不带情感且虎头蛇尾。蒂姆说了盖布如此渴望听到的所有话，然而，不知为何，感觉并没有什么大不了的。我认为这是因为在他们对话中一直浮现的另一件事。那是一种尴尬的事情，引起注意近乎残忍，但如果我不问就太失职了。所以，我紧张地问了。
The thing that I can't tell is, was your friendship as important to you, Tim, as it was to Gabe?
我无法判断的是，蒂姆，这段友谊对你来说像对盖布一样重要吗？
It was very important to me. I don't know how to answer that. I think-- it was incredibly important to me. I don't know that it was as important, but he was a very, very, very important friend to me.
它对我非常重要。我不知道该怎么回答。我想——它对我来说极其重要。我不知道是否一样重要，但他确实是我一个非常、非常、非常重要的朋友。
Do you have friends now that occupy the space that Gabe previously occupied?
你现在有朋友占据了盖布之前占据的空间吗？
I do.
我有。
You do?
你有？
I do. Yeah.
我有。是的。
We wrap up our conversation shortly after this, but the question still nags at me. So I asked Tim about it again the next day, when it was just the two of us talking.
我们在谈话后不久结束了对话，但这个问题仍然困扰着我。所以我第二天又问了蒂姆，当时只有我们俩。
It's a question I'm very self conscious about answering.
这是一个我回答时非常不自在的问题。
Why?
为什么？
Because I wouldn't say like he was a guy I knew. Yeah, he was a very good friend of mine.
因为我不会说他只是我认识的一个人。是的，他是我一个非常好的朋友。
Was he your best friend at any point?
他在任何时候是你最好的朋友吗？
No, see, now we're getting into things about best friends. And I think like--
不，看，现在我们要谈论关于最好朋友的事情了。我觉得——
Best friends can be a tier, not a person.
最好的朋友可以是一个层级，而不是一个人。
Best friend's a tier, not a person.
最好的朋友是一个层级，而不是一个人。
So was he on that tier?
那么他是在那个层级上吗？
So, whether Gabe was on that tier, he was certainly close to it. I don't know if I would throw him all the way up there.
所以，盖布是否在那个层级上，他当然很接近。我不知道我是不是会把他完全放在那个位置上。
It was startling to see the truth of the matter laid so bare. Tim just didn't love Gabe as much as Gabe loved Tim. And really, an imbalance in love-- isn't that ultimately the reason that all relationships end? I ran this by Gabe, that maybe there was a mismatch in their feelings for one another or in how they understood their relationship. He rejected that idea outright. He says he was there. He remembers what it felt like.
看着事实赤裸裸地摆在那里让人吃惊。蒂姆就是没有像盖布爱蒂姆那样爱盖布。真的，爱的不平衡——这难道不是所有关系结束的根本原因吗？我把这个想法告诉了盖布，也许他们对彼此的感情或者对关系的理解不匹配。他直接拒绝了这个想法。他说他当时在那里。他记得那种感觉。
This idea that we weren't best friends, I don't want to say it's a heresy, but it's just not true.
这种我们不是最好朋友的想法，我不想说这是异端邪说，但这只是不是事实。
But it's not true in your story.
但这在你的故事里不是事实。
Yeah, and I think-- yes.
是的，我想——是的。
It could be true in Tim's.
这在蒂姆的故事里可能是事实。
Yeah, and I just don't buy it. And I think that's self-preservation.
是的，我只是不买账。我认为那是自我保护。
I think a part of me had been jealous that Tim and Gabe got the chance to come to some understanding, a thing that my ex-friend made clear was not on the table for us. But it hadn't occurred to me that sitting down together and rehashing things might not lead to some sort of new common ground, that Tim could just strike a match on Gabe's memories and say, nope, you're wrong. It wasn't like that. I never felt that way about you.
我想我内心一部分曾嫉妒蒂姆和盖布有机会达成某种理解，而我的前朋友明确表示这在我们要讨论的范围内。但我没想到坐下来重新审视事情可能不会带来某种新的共同点，蒂姆竟然能点燃盖布记忆的火柴说，不，你错了。不是那样的。我从未那样看待你。
If that's what happens when you try to talk it out, yeah, no, thanks. I guess that's the problem when you write a one-man show, hoping it'll prompt someone to tell you the thing you've always wanted to hear. There's no guarantee that they'll say the lines you've assigned to them.
如果这就是尝试谈论之后的结果，是的，不，谢谢。我想这就是写一部独角戏，希望它能促使某人告诉你你一直想听的东西时所面临的问题。他们无法保证会说出你分配给他们的台词。
Aviva DeKornfeld is a producer at our show. Gabe Mollica's show, Solo, A Show About Friendship, reopens in October and runs in New York, LA, Boston, and Chicago. Tickets are at gabemollica.com. Coming up, can words succeed where sparkly platform shoes have failed? That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
艾薇瓦·德科恩菲尔德是我们节目的制作人。盖布·莫利卡的节目《独角戏，一部关于友谊的戏》十月重新开演，在纽约、洛杉矶、波士顿和芝加哥。门票请访问gabemollica.com。接下来，言语能否成功挽救闪亮厚底鞋未能挽救的东西？那将在稍后，来自芝加哥公共广播，当我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Say It to My Face. We have two stories today. Each of them is about a friendship where there is something that the two friends do not see eye to eye on, and that something is so fundamental that talking about it seems just explosive. And the friends have to decide, do we discuss this at all? We've arrived at Act 2 of our program. Act 2, "Pinky Swear."
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是“当面说出来”。我们今天有两个故事。每一个都是关于一段友谊，两个朋友在某件事上有分歧，而那件事是如此根本，谈论它似乎就会爆发。朋友们必须决定，我们讨论吗？我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“拉钩上吊”。
What's so interesting about the friends in this next story is that they talk every day. They are so close, best of besties. And yet, there is something that they have never talked about that is so big and so basic, that one of them wonders, are we really as close as I thought? Jasmine Garsd is one of the two friends. She's been on our show before. Jasmine lives here in the United States, in New York, but grew up in Buenos Aires.
下一个故事里的朋友最有趣的地方在于他们每天都谈话。他们非常亲密，最好的闺蜜。然而，有一些他们从未谈论过的事情，如此宏大且基本，以至于其中一个怀疑，我们真的像我想的那样亲密吗？贾斯敏·加斯德是那两个朋友之一。她以前上过我们的节目。贾斯敏住在我们这里，在美国纽约，但在布宜诺斯艾利斯长大。
On the day I left home, I sat in my kitchen with my best friend Gabbie. A taxi was waiting outside. We were leaving Argentina. I was 18. Listen, I said, barely able to make the words out without sobbing. There's something I want you to have.
我离开家的那天，我和我最好的朋友加比坐在厨房里。外面有一辆出租车在等着。我们要离开阿根廷了。我18岁。听着，我说，几乎无法在不抽泣的情况下说出这些话。有些东西我想让你拥有。
I gave you my sparkly platform shoes.
我把我的闪亮厚底鞋给了你。
It was a shitty gift. Como, really? It only means something to you. Seriously?
那是一份烂透了的礼物。天哪，真的吗？那只有对你有意义。认真的吗？
Yeah. Yeah, like how about your comic book collection?
是啊。是啊，那你那个漫画收藏集呢？
Era re especifico! Que carajos ibas a hacer con unas plataformas, tipo, fue como, okay, creo que las regalé al primer homeless que encontre.
那是特定的东西！鬼知道你要那双厚底鞋干什么，就像是，好吧，我想我把它送给遇到的第一个流浪汉了。
What the hell am I supposed to do with these, he says he thought to himself. Before he could say anything, Mama stuffed some cash savings in a pouch under her shirt and yelled, let's go. My grandma, Grandma Iaia, held my face in her bony hand and whispered something in my ear. I turned to Gabbie and told him, I'm going to move back as soon as I can. I promise.
我该拿这个怎么办，他说他当时心想。在他能说什么之前，妈妈往她衬衫下面的袋子里塞了一些现金储蓄，喊道，走吧。我的祖母，伊亚祖母，用她那双干瘪的手捧着我的脸，在我耳边说了些什么。我转向加比告诉他，我一有机会就会搬回来。我发誓。
That was more than 20 years ago. Gabbie is still my best friend. We talk all the time about everything. He knows when I'm going to go get my pap smear. I know when he's had a bad day, just by the tone of his voice. By now, some of my facial expressions are actually his. They just stuck to me, like the way I curl my lower lip when I find someone annoying.
那是20多年前的事了。加比仍然是我最好的朋友。我们总是无话不谈。他知道我什么时候要去做巴氏涂片。我凭他的声音就知道他什么时候过得不好。到现在，我的一些面部表情实际上是他的。它们只是粘在我身上了，就像我发现有人讨厌时撇下嘴唇的样子。
But as close as we are, we've never really talked about how I said I was going to move back, and I haven't followed through. It became a sort of unspoken rule. We cannot talk about this one small, enormous thing, until recently, when all the words we'd kept in over the years came spilling out. It happened by accident.
但尽管我们很亲密，我们从未真正谈论过我说过我要搬回来，却一直没做到这件事。这成了一条不成文的规定。我们不能谈论这个小而巨大的事情，直到最近，我们多年来憋在心里的所有话都喷涌而出。这是一次偶然发生的。
Of course, nothing truly happens by accident. We reached this boiling point by our own doing, by assuming we knew one another so well, we could read each other's minds. And to be fair, we often could. We've always understood one another instinctively, from the moment we met. We were 15. Back then, I mostly spent my summer vacations at the neighborhood park. That's where I first saw him.
当然，没有任何事情真的是偶然发生的。我们是通过自己的行为达到了这个临界点，通过自以为我们非常了解对方，我们可以读懂彼此的心思。公平地说，我们经常可以。我们总是凭本能理解彼此，从我们见面那一刻起。我们15岁。那时，我大部分暑假都在社区公园度过。我是在那里第一次见到他的。
He was lying out in the grass next to another friend of mine. A cigarette hung from his lip. He held a Quilmes beer in his hand. And I took one look at him and thought, what a badass. He took one look at me-- lanky, pale, blocking his sun-- and curled his lower lip. He was irritated.
他躺在草地上，在我另一个朋友旁边。一根烟挂在嘴唇上。他手里拿着一瓶基尔梅斯啤酒。我瞥了他一眼，心想，真是个混蛋。他瞥了我一眼——瘦长、苍白、挡住了他的阳光——撇了撇下嘴唇。他很烦躁。
Acá está como la amiga cheta. Tipo te vi como es como demasiado rubia y demasiado blanca, es una cheta insoportable, tal cual.
那个富家女朋友在那。看起来太金发、太白皙，是个令人难以忍受的富家女，确实如此。
Oh, look at this one. She looks too white. She must be insufferable. And just to prove him wrong, I took my first ever swig of beer. It was piss warm, but I chugged it down. This earned me some respect. We started joking.
哦，看看这个。她看起来太白了。她一定很令人讨厌。为了证明他错了，我喝了人生中第一口啤酒。那是温热的尿，但我还是把它灌了下去。这为我赢得了一些尊重。我们开始开玩笑了。
We were very different. I was a scared and secretly angry, nerdy Jewish girl. He was a brown kid who was scared of being outed as gay. But we quickly signaled to each other that we both came from homes where there was a lot of arguing that easily boiled over into physical fights. The adults in our lives, they often behaved like terrifying children.
我们很不同。我是个胆小、暗自愤怒、喜欢书呆子的犹太女孩。他是个棕色皮肤、害怕被出柜的男同性恋小孩。但我们很快向对方发出信号，我们都来自吵架很容易演变成肢体冲突的家庭。我们生活中的成年人，他们经常表现得像可怕的孩子。
I want so badly to tell you that from that day on, we became troublemakers. But Gabbie was not the bad boy I thought he was when we met. We were not "el terror del barrio," rebellious teens.
我非常想告诉你，从那天起，我们成了麻烦制造者。但加比不是我见面时以为的坏小子。我们不是“社区的恐怖”，叛逆的青少年。
Eramos ninos señora.
我们是孩子，女士。
We were, as he puts it, ninos señora, children who behaved like aunties. Our big act of rebellion was secretly drinking all of my mom's tea. We hung out in the park and just gossiped, smoking cheap national tobacco, ripping the filter off to feel tougher.
正如他所说，我们是“儿童女士”，行为像阿姨的孩子。我们最大的反叛行为是偷偷喝光我妈妈所有的茶。我们在公园里闲逛，只是八卦，抽着廉价的国产烟草，撕掉过滤嘴，让自己感觉更硬汉。
Comprar los cigarrillos mas baratos nacionales que podíamos encontrar--
买我们能找到的最便宜的国产烟——
The park, it was our island. And on it, we shared our fears, our obsessions, and our escape plans, which always involved moving far away. Things were not good at home. My parents, who were professors, had been unemployed for a whole year. Gabbie's-- his dad was a cab driver, his mom was a secretary-- they were barely making ends meet.
公园，那是我们的岛屿。在上面，我们分享我们的恐惧、我们的痴迷和我们的逃跑计划，这总是涉及搬到很远的地方。家里的情况不太好。我的父母，他们是教授，已经失业整整一年了。加比的——他爸爸是出租车司机，他妈妈是秘书——他们几乎难以维持生计。
Había noches donde como por ahí como cenábamos mate cocido con pan.
有几个晚上，我们甚至吃着温热的马黛茶和面包。
Sometimes, he'd come home from the park and find there was just tea and bread for dinner. At the end of each night, we'd say goodbye, see you tomorrow. I'd go back home and sometimes slip into my Grandma Iaia's bed, next to her. She kept a tiny plastic radio under her pillow, which blasted the news all night.
有时候，他从公园回到家发现晚餐只有茶和面包。每天晚上结束时，我们会说再见，明天见。我会回家，有时溜进伊亚祖母的床上，躺在她身边。她在枕头下藏着一个小塑料收音机，整晚播放新闻。
And over the years, the news got increasingly worse. 10% unemployment, 15% unemployment, 17% unemployment. People started just breaking into supermarkets. The police responded brutally. They killed protesters just a few minutes from my house. We had three replacement presidents in the span of one month. Lying next to Iaia's radio was like falling asleep to a muffled doomsday clock.
多年来，新闻越来越糟糕。10%的失业率，15%的失业率，17%的失业率。人们开始冲进超市。警察进行了残酷的镇压。他们在离我家几分钟路程的地方杀死了抗议者。我们在一个月内换了三任总统。躺在伊亚的收音机旁，就像是在闷响的世界末日倒计时中入睡。
By the end of the year, my family decided to go. It felt like now or never. At the time, there was an exodus out of Argentina. There was a saying I heard a few times back then, "el último en salir, apague la luz." Last one out, get the lights. In the days and weeks after my departure, Gabbie watched one friend after another pick up and leave. And he was still there. He says he felt anchored to a sinking ship.
年底时，我家决定离开。感觉是现在或永远不。当时，阿根廷正在发生大迁徙。那时我听过几次一句谚语，“最后一个离开的人，关灯。”最后一个离开的，关上灯。我离开后的日子和几周里，加比看着一个又一个朋友收拾行李离开。他还在那里。他说他感觉自己锚定在了一艘沉船上。
Me enojaba, me frustraba. me sentía como que quedaba anclado en el mismo lugar, que todos podían, que la mayoría podía elegir irse a donde quisiese.
我很生气，我很沮丧。我感觉自己像被锚定在同一个地方，每个人都可以，大多数人可以选择去任何想去的地方。
I was angry, he says. I was frustrated. I felt like I was stuck in place. Everyone else could choose to go wherever they wanted, but not me. I have to stay here.
我非常生气，他说。我感到很沮丧。我感觉自己被困在原地。其他人可以选择去任何地方，但我不能。我得待在这里。
Todo el resto, el resto de ellos pueden elegir a dónde irse, a vos no, vos te tenés que quedar acá.
其他人，他们其他人可以选择去哪，你不能，你必须待在这里。
He dreamt of studying fashion, becoming a designer. But his mother had sat him down and told him university was not in the cards. They needed him to get a second job. So he started waiting tables. The tips were meager. No one was eating out.
他梦想学习时尚，成为一名设计师。但他妈妈坐下来告诉他，大学不在考虑范围内。他们需要他去打第二份工。所以他开始端盘子。小费微薄。没人出去吃饭。
Meanwhile, for me, it felt like I'd gotten thrown into the deep end of America with no life jacket. We lived in a motel in Southern California. I worked a lot of jobs-- dawn at a bakery, afternoons at the supermarket. Weekends, I sold cowboy boots at a store. Back then, Mama was always yelling at me. There was no A for effort. There was just, keep swimming or you'll drown.
与此同时，对我来说，感觉我被扔进了美国的深水区，没有救生衣。我们住在南加州的一家汽车旅馆里。我打了很多工——清晨在面包店，下午在超市。周末，我在店里卖牛仔靴。那时，妈妈总是冲我大吼。努力没有奖励。只有，继续游泳，否则你就会淹死。
Wake up, Jasmine. Enroll in community college, Jasmine. Go to bed, Jasmine. But before bed, I always tried to call Gabbie on Skype or with these international calling cards they sold at liquor stores. I'd tell him about whoever I had a crush on. He'd tell me about the pants he'd designed and made for himself.
醒醒，贾斯敏。去社区大学注册，贾斯敏。上床睡觉，贾斯敏。但睡觉前，我总是尝试通过Skype或者他们在酒铺卖的国际电话卡给加比打电话。我会告诉他我暗恋的人。他会告诉我他为自己设计和制作的裤子。
In the background of these conversations, there was always my promise to return. Whenever I'd have a bad day, whenever my creepy boss would give me another unsolicited massage, I'd call and tell him, fuck this place. I'm so glad I'm coming back soon. Whenever Gabbie would have a bad day, when he'd get into an argument with his family or his boss would throw a tantrum, he'd sigh and say, can't wait for you to come back.
在这些对话的背景中，总有我承诺会回来。每当我过得不好，每当我的猥琐老板给我按摩时，我会打电话告诉他，去他的地方。我真高兴我很快就要回来了。每当加比过得不好，当他和家人争吵或者他的老板发脾气时，他会叹气说，真等不及你回来。
But returning at this point was impossible. I couldn't afford to even visit, let alone move back. We just needed time, we figured. I needed time. Two more years, maybe three. Three at most. In the meantime, I started making money. Not a lot, but I felt I could help my family for the first time. I started getting a taste of an independence I could never have imagined back home.
但当时回来是不可能的。我连探亲的钱都没有，更别说搬回来了。我们认为我们只是需要时间。我需要时间。再过两年，也许三年。最多三年。在此期间，我开始赚钱了。虽然不多，但我感觉自己第一次能帮到家里。我开始尝到了一种在家乡无法想象的独立。
Still, Argentina was always in my rear view mirror, beautiful and resilient, alive, even in its wreckage. Gabbie would tell me about all these new things he was doing, poetry readings, a protest, a road trip. Everyone was hurting back home, but they managed to hustle and enjoy life. Meanwhile, me, I was making money in the USA, but the closest thing I had to a friend was the flatulent co-worker I took my cigarette breaks with.
尽管如此，阿根廷总是在我的后视镜里，美丽而坚韧，活着，即使是在它的残骸中。加比会告诉我他正在做的所有这些新事情，诗歌朗诵、抗议、公路旅行。家里每个人都过得很艰难，但他们设法打拼并享受生活。与此同时，我，我在美国赚钱，但我最接近朋友的东西是我休息时一起抽烟的那个会放屁的同事。
It didn't matter, though, because I knew someday soon, I would make a U-turn. I'd move back. And when I did, I'd join Gabbie in his new adventures. Everything would make sense again. And I knew that coming back home could be done because I'd seen my own family do it. Back in the '70s, during the dictatorship, my parents had left Argentina, and they'd returned when it was over. Gabbie and I would always sign off our phone calls the same way. I'd tell him, see you soon. And he'd say--
不过那没关系，因为我知道不久的将来，我会掉头。我会搬回来。当我搬回来时，我会加入加比的新冒险。一切都会再次变得有意义。我知道回家是可以做到的，因为我亲眼见过我家人那样做。早在70年代，独裁时期，我的父母离开过阿根廷，当一切结束时他们又回来了。加比和我总是用同样的方式结束电话。我会告诉他，很快见。他会说——
Te amo hasta el cielo y devuelta Jazmina de mi corazón.
我爱你直到天空又回来，我心爱的贾斯敏。
Jazmina, my love, I love you to the sky and back. See you soon.
贾斯敏，我的爱人，我爱你直到天空又回来。很快见。
I went back to visit in 2011. I didn't tell anyone I was coming back, not even Gabbie. I thought it would be a wonderful surprise to just show up one day, unannounced.
2011年我回去探亲。我没告诉任何人我要回来，连加比也没告诉。我以为突然出现在某天，给他们一个惊喜会很棒。
That night, I got into the city, went to my aunt's house, ate something, and fell asleep. The telephone woke me up before sunrise. They told me that Grandma Iaia had been found at the foot of the stairway at her nursing home, unconscious. Her skull was cracked. She'd been rushed to the hospital.
那天晚上，我到了城里，去了我姨妈家，吃了一些东西，睡着了。电话在日出前把我吵醒。他们告诉我伊亚祖母在养老院楼梯脚下被发现，昏迷不醒。她的头骨裂开了。她被紧急送往医院。
In my memory, it feels like I'm running underwater, too slow to make it in time. And by the time I got to the hospital, the police had arrived. She had died. The circumstances were murky, and it could have involved violence, so this was now an official investigation. The cops wouldn't let me in. Dazed, I walked outside and looked for a public phone. There was only one person I knew to call--
在我的记忆中，感觉就像我在水下奔跑，太慢了，没能赶上。当我到达医院时，警察已经到了。她已经去世了。情况很模糊，可能涉及暴力，所以现在这是正式调查。警察不让我进去。我神志恍惚地走出去，寻找公用电话。我只知道要打给一个人——
Yo estaba durmiendo.
我当时在睡觉。
Gabbie. He was asleep. It was early. I'm home, I told him. Home, home? Home, home. I need you to come to the hospital. When he arrived, I fell apart in his arms. In the next few days, I went to the police to badger them. Hey, when can I get her body back? The officer was too busy watching a soccer game to see me. I could hear them all yelling at the screen in the back office. I'd forgotten about this part of Argentina, how broken things could be.
加比。他在睡觉。时间还早。我到家了，我告诉他。真的到家了？真的到家了。我要你来医院。当他到达时，我在他怀里崩溃了。接下来的几天，我去找警察死缠烂打。嘿，我什么时候能拿到她的遗体？警察忙着看足球比赛，顾不上看我。我能听到他们在后台办公室冲着屏幕大喊大叫。我忘记了阿根廷的这一部分，事情能变得多么破碎。
At night, Gabbie would crawl into bed with me. We'd spoon and I'd cry, and he'd whisper, come on now, Jazmina. You know how things are here with the police. But all of a sudden, I had this deep, terrifying feeling of wanting to leave. I'd never felt that before. I didn't know what to make of it. And I couldn't tell Gabbie. I worried it would be too hurtful, so I kept it from him. I think it was the first time in my life I kept anything from him. He'd drift off to sleep, and I'd stay awake for hours.
晚上，加比会爬进我的床上。我们相拥着，我哭泣，他会耳语，好了，贾斯敏。你知道这里警察处理事情的方式。但突然间，我产生了一种想要离开的深层、可怕的感觉。我以前从未有过那种感觉。我不知道该怎么办。我无法告诉加比。我担心那会太伤人，所以我对他隐瞒了。我想那是我一生中第一次对他隐瞒任何事情。他会陷入沉睡，而我会清醒几个小时。
A few days later, the cops called. I was to identify Iaia's body at the city morgue. Gabbie went with me. When they rolled out her body, Gabbie saw me drowning. He found my hand and whispered, Jazz--
几天后，警察打电话来。我要去城市太平间辨认伊亚的尸体。加比陪着我。当他们推开她的尸体时，加比看见我在溺水。他抓住我的手，耳语道，贾斯——
Cerra los ojos.
闭上眼睛。
--close your eyes. When he identified her body, he gave me a gift to remember her as one of the last times I saw her. The day I left, she was holding my face, whispering, "Jazmin. No te olvides de nosotros." Don't forget us.
——闭上眼睛。当他辨认出她的尸体时，他给了我一份礼物，让我能记住她，就像我最后一次见到她时那样。我离开的那天，她捧着我的脸，低语道，“贾斯敏。别忘了我们。”别忘了我们。
After Iaia died, I felt like I had failed at the most important things, to hold on to the people I loved tight enough, to stay connected enough, or to, at the very least, go back home in time enough to say Como me voy a olvidar de vos. How could I ever forget you? Thank you. Goodbye. I felt guilty.
伊亚去世后，我觉得我在最重要的事情上失败了，没能足够紧紧地抱住我所爱的人，没能保持足够的联系，或者至少没能及时回到家说：我怎么会忘记你呢？谢谢。再见。我感到内疚。
Gabbie and me, we still talked every day, but whenever it came up, me visiting or moving back, I could hear myself making excuses, even when they weren't exactly true. I can't afford a ticket. I don't have enough vacation days. Too much work.
加比和我，我们仍然每天说话，但每当谈到这个，我探亲或搬回来时，我都能听到自己在找借口，即使那些借口并不完全属实。我付不起票钱。我没有足够的假期。工作太忙。
And then last summer, I ran out of excuses. My job sent me to Argentina to report on the FIFA World Cup in 2022. That's when it happened. Gabbie and I, we finally talked about it, about how 20-some years ago, we sat in my kitchen, and I made a promise that I haven't kept. When I hopped out of the cab and saw Gabbie walk towards me, he looked as handsome as ever.
去年夏天，我的借口用光了。我的工作派我去阿根廷报道2022年FIFA世界杯。就在那时，这件事发生了。加比和我，我们终于谈到了这件事，谈到了20多年前，我们坐在我厨房里，我做了一个我没能遵守的承诺。当我跳下出租车看到加比向我走来时，他看起来一如既往地帅气。
Gabbie! Hola.
加比！你好。
Que onda, Jasmina? Estas igual!
怎么了，贾斯敏？你一点都没变！
We almost immediately snap back into it-- goofed off, pretended to be gymnasts on the jungle gym. He's doing great. He's a modeling agent, which he loves. He's dating a really nice guy who forces him to eat healthy. Somehow, his childhood cat, Fiona, is still alive. It felt so good to just be together, like in the old days. And so I got that nagging question. Is it time to come back home? I blurted it out in the middle of our conversation.
我们几乎立刻回到了过去——胡闹，假装在攀爬架上做体操。他做得很好。他是模特经纪人，他很喜欢这个。他和一个强迫他健康饮食的好男人约会。不知为何，他童年的猫，菲奥娜，仍然活着。能在一起感觉真好，就像过去一样。所以我提出了那个困扰我的问题。是时候回家了吗？我在对话中脱口而出。
You know, my family's always like, oh, I can put you in touch with so-and-so who runs a radio station. But I don't have the contacts. I made my-- what?
你知道，我家人总是说，哦，我可以让你和某个经营广播电台的人联系。但我没有联系方式。我做了我的——什么？
There it was. Like a nervous tic, I said it, the promise followed by the excuse. I'm going to move back home. I just can't right now because of work, which is when Gabbie looked at me. His lower lip curled and finally said what he really felt. He remembers the moment as well as I do.
就在那里。像神经性抽搐一样，我说出来了，承诺伴随着借口。我要搬回家。我只是现在因为工作不行，那时加比看着我。他撇下下唇，终于说出了他真正感受到的。他记得那一刻，正如我也记得的一样。
Boluda, como, deja de chamuyarme, como, basta, saltemos esto, saltemos este loop que tenemos hace años donde tipo voy a volver.
笨蛋，就像，别再忽悠我了，就像，够了，让我们跳过这个，跳过我们多年来陷入的那个我会回来的怪圈。
Come on, sis. Stop bullshitting me. Enough. Let's jump out of this loop we've been stuck in for years, where you say you're moving back or you want to move back, and it's like, it's not going to happen. Let's move on.
算了吧，姐妹。别再忽悠我了。够了。让我们跳出我们多年来陷入的那个怪圈，在那里你说你要搬回来或者你想搬回来，而就像，这不会发生的。让我们继续前进。
O quiero volver, y es como, tipo no va a pasar, ya está, pasamos esto. move on, ¿entendés?, y sigamos como a otra página.
或者我想回来，而就像，不会发生了，够了，跨过去。继续前进，你懂吗？让我们翻过这一页。
All of this, this was new information for me. Gabbie was doing this thing that, in Spanish, we call desahogarse. I suppose it translates into venting, but it literally means "to undrown oneself," to spit out everything you've been holding in, no matter what.
所有这一切，这是给我的新信息。加比正在做我们西班牙语里称之为“desahogarse”的事。我想这翻译成“发泄”，但它字面意思是“把自己从溺水中解脱出来”，吐出所有你一直在忍受的东西，无论如何。
Hubo momentos en los que te sentiste como irritado, como boluda ya no tenes que decir eso, está todo bien?
有没有你感到烦躁的时刻，比如，笨蛋，你不需要再说那个了，一切都好吗？
I asked him, were there moments where you felt irritated? Like, come on, girl. You don't have to keep saying this. We're good.
我问他，有没有你感到烦躁的时刻？比如，算了吧，姑娘。你不必一直说这个。我们很好。
Desde el momento en que lo entendí tipo todas las veces que lo has dicho me sentí irritado. Tipo como okay, pará. Que pare. Que pare de decirme tipo esto porque Cómo es al pedo. ¿Para que me lo dice? Tipo no sé.
从我明白的那一刻起，你每次说的那些话我都感到烦躁。比如，好吧，停下。让它停下。让它停止对我说那种事，因为那是白费力气。为什么你要告诉我那个？比如我不知道。
Gabbie says, of course. From the moment, I understood it. Like, every time you'd said it, I felt annoyed. Like, stop. Just stop. It was like, what is the deal here? What are you telling me this for?
加比说，当然。从那一刻起，我就明白了。就像，每次你那样说，我就感到烦恼。就像，停下。只管停下。就像，这到底是搞什么？你为什么跟我说这些？
Como...Porque sentí que me lo decias a mi para dejarme tranquilo a mi. Entendes? Y finalmente era como...no!
就像……因为我觉得你是为了让我平静下来才那样说的。懂吗？而最终它是……不！
It felt like you were saying it to calm me down, and I was like, no. Looking back, he's kind of right. I did say these things out of guilt. I tried to soften things by talking about how challenging it was for me up north, which he says actually didn't help.
感觉你是为了让我平静下来才那样说的，而我当时就像，不。回过头看，他是对的。我确实因为内疚才说了那些话。我试图通过谈论我在北方是多么具有挑战性来缓和气氛，他说这其实并没用。
Era escuchar quejarte de algo que yo nunca tuve la posibilidad de hacer. No?
听到你抱怨我从来没机会做的事情。不是吗？
It was hearing you complain about something I never had the chance to do. He didn't want to hear that, not when he was barely making ends meet. And he says the moment he realized that I was never going to move back was years ago when my Grandma Iaia died, the same moment, I suppose, it became clear to me.
听到你抱怨我从来没机会做的事情。他不想听那个，尤其是在他几乎入不敷出的时候。他说他意识到我永远不会搬回来的那一刻是多年前我祖母伊亚去世的时候，那一刻，我想，也变得对我来说很清楚。
Ahí fue cuando entendí, fue como como okay, Jasmin no va a volver y automáticamente me cayo esa ficha de que ya no tenias a tus abuelas, acá ya no tenias a nada que te arraigue.
就在那时候我明白了，就像是好吧，贾斯敏不会回来了，我立刻意识到了你这里已经没有你的祖父母了，你在这里已经没有任何东西能把你锚定了。
It immediately hit me that you no longer had your grandparents here. So I was like, OK, nothing is anchoring her here. But you were here, I say.
那一刻我立刻意识到你在这里已经没有祖父母了。所以我心想，好吧，没有什么能把她锚在这里了。但你在这里，我说。
Pero vos estabas.
是的。但作为朋友，也就是，我也不希望你为了我而回来。懂吗？现在不。在另一个时候，如果你在我们23岁时那样对我说，我会很乐意你为了我而回来。懂吗？
Si. Pero como amigo, es decir, tampoco como hubiese querido que vuelvas por mi. Se entiende? No ahora. En otro momento si me lo decias cuando teníamos 23 años me hubiese encantado la idea de que pudieses volver por mi. ¿Entendes?
加比说，是的，但作为你的朋友，我是说，我不会希望你为了我而回来，现在不是。在我生命中的另一个时候，比如如果你在我们23岁时那样对我说，我会很乐意你为了我而回来，你知道吗？我知道。但我不仅是为了他才说出来的。我还说是因为我太害怕了。害怕我正在漂走，而我需要相信我还有一个家，一个我完美契合的地方。我仍然想要相信这一点。
Gabbie says, yeah, but as your friend, I mean, I wouldn't have wanted you to come back for me, not now. At some other time in my life, like if you had said this to me when we were 23, I would have loved for you to come back for me, you know? I do know. But I wasn't just saying it for him. I was also saying it because I was terrified. Terrified that I was drifting away, and I needed to believe I still had a home, a place where I fit in perfectly. I still want to believe that.
你觉得我还是阿根廷人吗？
¿Pensás que todavía soy argentina?
当我问他这个问题时，我全身都紧绷了。你仍然认为我是阿根廷人吗？
My whole body tensed up when I asked him this question. Do you still think of me as Argentine?
嗯——我不想让你误解，但我……不。
Mm-- no quiero que te lo tomes a mal pero...no.
哇。
Wow.
加比说，别误会，但不是。
Gabbie said, don't take this the wrong way, but no.
你很拉丁化。但我不知道，如果像……我不知道，今天我不会把你介绍为阿根廷朋友。
Sos re latina. Pero no se, si como...no se, hoy por hoy no te presento como una amiga argentina.
他说，你很拉丁化，但我不知道。今天，我不会把你介绍为我的阿根廷朋友。你是我的北美朋友。我很久以前就意识到了，但不是有意的，我开始称你为我的“gringa”（美国佬）朋友。
He says, you are very Latina, but I don't know. Nowadays, I don't introduce you as my Argentine friend. You're my North American friend. I realized a long time ago, but without meaning to, I started calling you my gringa friend.
那是很久以前我意识到的，就像无意中那样，但我把你介绍为我的北美朋友。
Eso hace tiempo me di cuenta, tipo como sin quererlo, tipo pero te presento como mi amiga norteamericana.
哇。
Wow.
那个混蛋。作为阿根廷人是我的整个身份。它是我的主题曲。这就是我在愚蠢的日常生活中看待自己的方式。这算什么？我以前听过这种话。
That son of a bitch. Being from Argentina is like my whole identity. It's like my theme song. That's how I think of myself as I move through my stupid everyday life. What the fuck? I've heard this kind of thing before.
我一生中，听过拉丁美洲人这样谈论美国的拉丁裔人。当他们说“哦，某某人是哥伦比亚人，但是从美国来的”时，他们的声音会降低半个八度，就像那是一种绝症一样。我想我只是没意识到我现在住在声音降低的那部分里。加比说他仍然爱我，即使我的某些部分他现在不完全理解。
My whole life, I had heard Latin Americans talk about US Latinos this way. People's voice would go down half an octave when they say, oh, so-and-so is Colombian, but from the US, like it's some kind of terminal illness. I guess I just didn't realize that now I live in the voice drop. Gabbie says he still loves me, even if there's parts of me that he now doesn't fully get.
你不回来也没关系。我觉得很好。这就像……即使你理解不回来也没必要，我觉得这甚至是健康的。
Que esta bien que no vuelvas. Me parece bien. Es como...Me parece hasta sano que puedas entender que no hace falta que vuelvas.
你不回来也没关系，他说。我觉得很好。甚至感觉这很健康，因为你能理解你不必回来。我很久以前就停止等待你了。于是，他一举释放了我那青少年时期的承诺，你原以为那会是一种巨大的解脱。但说实话，感觉糟透了。即使我这么说，我仍然不停地想，但等等，也许。也许过几年我会搬回去。也许当我老了的时候。我不想要从我的誓言中解脱，而我不知道那让我们处于什么境地。
It's OK for you not to come back for me, he says. It's healthy. I stopped waiting for you a long time ago. And so, in one fell swoop, he releases me from my teenage promise, which you would think was a huge relief. But to be honest, it feels terrible. Even as I say this, I keep thinking, but wait, maybe. Maybe I'll move back in a few more years. Maybe when I'm old. I don't want to be free from my oath, and I don't know where that leaves us.
每当我想到我和加比的友谊，想到让我们在远距离保持联系的粘合剂是什么，我都会回到这段记忆。它发生在小时候，我们在公园见面的第一天。那天晚上，有一场夏季风暴。我们所有的朋友都跑回家了。只有我和他。“大洪水！”我们戏剧性地喊道。伟大的洪水。我们站在屋檐下躲避大雨，大笑着。
Every time I think about my friendship with Gabbie, about what the glue is that keeps us together at a distance, I go back to this one memory. It happened back when we were kids, on that first day when we met in the park. That evening, there was a summer storm. All our friends ran home. It was just me and him. "El diluvio!" we yelled dramatically. The great flood. We laughed as we stood under a ledge to avoid the downpour.
我不想回家。那时我从不想。我不需要向他解释。我们从一开始就深刻地了解彼此。他全身湿透，向我微笑着。他棕色的眼睛充满了顽皮，说，“你想在这里多待一会儿吗？”你想在这里多待一会儿吗？我感受到了那种第一次被说话的人所带来的兴奋的冲击。是的，我回答说。于是我们一起站在屋檐下，看着周围的世界分崩离析。
I didn't want to go back home. I never did back then. I didn't have to explain it to him. We just knew each other profoundly from the start. He smiled at me, drenched. His brown eyes filled with mischief and said, Queres quedarte acá un rato más? Want to stay here a while longer? I felt the rush of excitement of someone who has just been spoken to for the first time. Yes, I answered. So we stood under the ledge together, watching the world around us come undone.
贾斯敏·加斯德。她第一次为她的播客《最后一杯》采访加比，我猜这节目正式是关于足球明星里奥·梅西和阿根廷的，但实际上，如果你听了，它是关于更多东西的，关于离家，关于在另一个国家做一个局外人。它提供英语和西班牙语版本，在任何你能获得播客的地方都可以听到，由NPR和Futuro Studios制作。贾斯敏今天为我们节目讲述的故事是由纳迪亚·雷曼制作的。
Jasmine Garsd. She first interviewed Gabbie for her podcast, The Last Cup, La Ultima Copa, which I guess officially is about soccer star Leo Messi and Argentina, but really, if you hear it, is about so much more, about leaving home, about being an outsider in another country. It is available in English and in Spanish, wherever you get your podcasts, produced by NPR and Futuro Studios. Jasmine's story for our show today was produced by Nadia Reiman.
["现在就说" - 汉娜·贾达古]
["SAY IT NOW" BY HANNAH JADAGU]
我们的节目今天由莉莉·沙利文制作，由劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基编辑。今天参与节目制作的人员包括比姆·阿德温米、詹姆斯·贝内特二世、詹达伊·邦兹、佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、迈克尔·科米特、安德烈·洛佩兹·克鲁扎多、瓦莱丽·基普尼斯、托宾·洛、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、瑞安·鲁梅里、弗朗西丝·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。
Our program was produced today by Lilly Sullivan and edited by Laura Starecheski. The people who put our show together today include Bim Adewunmi, James Bennett II, Jendayi Bonds, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Andrea Lopez Cruzado, Valerie Kipnis, Tobin Low, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Ryan Rumery, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
我们的执行编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜勒拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。今天特别感谢格雷格·沃洛奇、乔纳森·戈德斯坦、劳伦·冈萨雷斯和凯蒂·西蒙。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体播放我们超过800集的档案。如果你被想听什么而困住，那里有像在一家有格调的社区书店里的员工推荐。thisamericanlife.org。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuel Berry. Special thanks today to Greg Walloch, Jonathan Goldstein, Lauren Gonzalez, and Katie Simon. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free. If you are stuck for something to listen to, there are staff recommendations like in a classy neighborhood bookstore. thisamericanlife.org.
《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交流中心传送到公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。他在英格兰的堂弟米尔特总是邮寄给他香肠，就像单独的香肠。今天早上我路过托雷的办公桌时看见他在拆包裹。我当时想，那是什么，托雷？他告诉我——
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. His cousin, Milt, in England, is always mailing him sausages, like individual sausages. I was walking by Torey's desk this morning and saw him opening this package. I was like, what is that, Torey? He told me--
弥尔顿的又一杰作。
Another banger from Milton.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
["现在就说" - 汉娜·贾达古]
["SAY IT NOW" BY HANNAH JADAGU]
[汉娜·贾达古的《现在就说出来》]